[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
swinging
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
uh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
bye
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and thank you for joining us today
for our first product premiere of 2022.
as always we love kicking off the year
with ces as we roll out new products and
preview some of the next generation
technologies we've been working on
it's never been a more exciting time to
be in the semiconductor business
we are in a high performance computing
megacycle today
from digital transformation and
businesses to ai and supercomputing to
the devices that we rely on for school
and work computing has never been more
essential to our daily lives and we see
this trend only increasing in the years
ahead
whether in pcs the cloud gaming or
supercomputers amd is all about pushing
the envelope on high performance
computing
and as a result amd products are
everywhere we focus on deep code
development with our partners to build
solutions for today's most demanding
experiences and challenges
it all starts in the cloud where amd
powers the services that connect
billions and helps make us all more
productive from virtually anywhere and
at any time
microsoft teams and 365
meta tencent meeting twitter zoom and
many more use our epic processors
and in the enterprise leading fortune
500 companies are increasingly selecting
epic to power their
infrastructure and as you all know we
just love pcs
the last few years have seen tremendous
innovation and our next generation ryzen
and radeon processors will raise the bar
for the experiences we can expect from
commercial creator and gaming pcs
we also love gamers
because they're always looking for more
performance to enable the most immersive
experience possible
which is why we're so proud that our
ryzen and radeon technologies power the
best experiences from pcs to game
consoles to cloud gaming
in automotive we've also partnered with
tesla to enable the next generation of
in-dash infotainment
and in phones our partnership with
samsung will enable new mobile gaming
experiences as we bring low power rdna 2
graphics to their next generation
flagship socs
now turning to pcs
we've seen remarkably strong growth in
pcs over the last two years with overall
shipments increasing 30 percent and
notebook shipments growing by an amazing
49
and as a result we shift a record 350
million pcs in 2021 as an industry
today we're going to focus on what comes
next for pcs including new notebook apus
and gpus desktop gpus and ryzen desktop
processors
let's get started with our new ryzen
mobile processors and next generation
notebooks
since launching our first verizon mobile
processors at ces in 2018 we have
consistently executed our
multi-generational roadmap and delivered
a new ryzen mobile processor every year
as a result we have built deep
partnerships with all of the top pc oems
as they have also expanded their
adoption of ryzen mobile in each new
generation
in 2021 our partners launched more than
150 premium ultra-thin commercial and
gaming designs
resulting in amd achieving record mobile
processor market share
now it's time for what's next
today i'm proud to launch our amd ryzen
6000 series mobile processors
that deliver leadership performance
battery life and much much more
we have so much new technology in the
6000 series it starts with an updated
zen 3 plus cpu core optimized
specifically to deliver leadership
performance per watt for notebooks
and i know this is one the community has
been requesting for the first time we
are bringing our dna 2 graphics to our
notebook apus
the rda2 graphics upgrade brings a
massive increase in performance compared
to our prior generation and is the same
graphics i p powering the latest
generation consoles high-end gaming pcs
and teslas
for increased performance and greater
power efficiency ryzen 6000 apus are
built using tsmc's six nanometer process
technology
and to enable our partners to build the
ultimate notebooks we paired our
leadership mobile processor with the
latest in memory and connectivity
technologies
including low power ddr5 memory usb4 and
wi-fi 6e
performance is just amazing
ryzen 6000 powered notebooks feature our
fastest ryzen processor ever
with boost speeds up to 5 gigahertz
we're delivering an average of 1.3 x
faster performance compared to the 5000
series across a wide range of compute
intensive benchmarks
and with an rdna 2 graphics built in
it's a massive leap
double the performance
this is just an enormous generational
uplift compared to our ryzen 5000 mobile
processors which were already the best
available
now looking at the application
performance compared to our prior
generation
verizon 6000 apus deliver up to 69
faster video editing more than double
the 3d rendering performance and double
the 1080p gaming performance
we've also worked closely with our
customers and partners to enable unique
security features
to better address the evolving security
threats facing the industry i'm very
proud to announce that ryzen 6000 series
will be the first pc processors that
integrate the microsoft pluton security
processor
our code development work with microsoft
eliminates entire attack vectors on
notebooks better protecting critical
data like system credentials user
identities encryption keys and personal
information
the microsoft pluton processor combined
with our other security features
delivers the most innovative security in
a pc processor
now the performance and security are
great but when it comes to notebooks
battery life is so important
and this is where the efficiency of our
zen 3 plus core and 6 nanometer process
technology really shine we've made
significant design optimizations and
enhancements in our ryzen 6000
processors to deliver leadership
performance per watt including an
all-new adaptive power control framework
and new power management features that
will enable up to 24 hours of video
playback on a single charge
put all of that together and you simply
have the world's best all-around
notebook processor
to show you ryzen 6000 in action for the
very first time and tell you a bit more
here's jason benta general manager of
our oem pc business
[Music]
thank you lisa
at the heart of ryzen is zen
amd's award-winning core architecture
driving the computing revolution
in 2021
we launched the highly successful
ryzen 5000 with the high performance zen
three core
it set the performance standard for
gaming content creation and productivity
in premium notebooks
in ryzen 6000 we introduced the zen 3
plus core bringing into perfect balance
high performance and incredible
efficiency
for zen 3 plus we deliver stronger
performance that can really be felt by
gamers creators and professionals
at the same time
that performance uplift needed to come
with substantial core power reduction
this enables longer battery life
reduced fan noise and a cooler notebook
in those ryzen 6000 platforms
50 new power management features were
implemented since our ryzen 5000
platform
we developed a brand new set of deep
sleep states to take the core to an
extremely low power state in between
operations
and finally we re-architected our system
management firmware to be smarter
our new adaptive power management can
learn from the os
and utilizes more on dye sensors to
adjust speed more quickly and accurately
amd is the only team that can deliver a
performance core and an efficient core
in the same core now let's see what it
can do
the zen 3 core shines in cases where
performance really matters
we've upped our game in raw apu
horsepower logging substantial gains in
both single thread and multi-thread
computes cinebench r23 single thread has
improved by 11 percent
and multi-thread has improved by 28
a combination of improved frequency and
enhanced clock residency delivers
performance across the most demanding
applications
but when we translate that to real
productivity and content creation
applications the result is even stronger
pc mark 10 extended which blends a suite
of real world applications
shows a 28 percent gain compared to our
ryzen 5000 series product
these ryzen 6000 performance gains also
come with exceptional battery life in
the latest laptop designs
today's laptops are becoming a critical
part of our lives from virtual meetings
to streaming and creating
but nothing is more frustrating than a
noisy fan or a low battery warning
during an important zoom call or a
thrilling netflix episode
therefore we put power consumption front
and center and zen 3 plus
over a 30 percent system power reduction
when running microsoft teams
40 when playing netflix
these improvements mean a quieter cooler
system and the battery life to ensure
your laptop lasts
ryzen 6000 also brings the most advanced
graphic engine available in a laptop
for the first time we are bringing the
incredible rdna graphics architecture
into a mobile apu
the ryzen 6000 graphics engine is simply
phenomenal
it offers up to 12 rd and a2 compute
units
setting a new standard for apu graphics
it is the first mobile apu to support
hardware ray tracing
compared to ryzen 5000 graphics the rdna
2 engine supports a 2x larger cache
the overall graphics engine is 50
percent larger than the prior generation
of ryzen mobile
and ryzen 6000 is optimized for fidelity
fx super resolution
and microsoft directx 12 ultimate
the combination of zen 3 plus rdna 2 and
fsr enables the dream of true 1080p
aaa gaming on an ultra thin apu only
notebook
we told you that ryzen 6000 delivers
twice the performance of ryzen 5000
but let's look at it against other
products in market
we see it as significantly faster than
the integrated xe graphics available in
the tiger lake 1165 g7 notebook
but let's look at it against discrete
solutions in market as well
annually over 19 million notebooks are
sold with an entry class discrete gpu
such as the g-force mx-450
that adds system price and reduces
battery life in your notebook
ryzen 6000 apu graphics also beats that
mx450 discreet graphics hands down
but ryzen 6000 graphics gets even better
last year we launched fidelity fx super
resolution
this technology unlocks faster frame
rates through real-time upscaling of
game content
we're bringing this capability to the
ryzen 6000 apu
for this next demo i want to show you
far cry 6 a triple a title recently
released from ubisoft
and here we'll compare the ryzen 7 6800u
running with fidelityfx super resolution
on and off to show a dramatic difference
in frame rate
59 frames per second average of gaming
performance on this exciting visually
rich title
this represents over a 50 percent gain
really showing the power of fsr on an
apu
but this is not just the case with one
title
these aaa results spread across the
games we tested on ryzen 6000
here we focused on some of the more
intense gaming titles in the market
today
this is what only amd can do in a
notebook by bringing together the best
core
graphics and software
we unlock a new paradigm in pure apu
gaming
far cry 6 call of duty vanguard and
godfall demanding triple a titles
true 60 fps 1080p
aaa gaming on an ultra thin apu is now
possible with ryzen 6000
ryzen 6000 also introduces an all-new
connected laptop platform
first
there's an all-new high-speed usb4
this delivers 2x the transfer speed
compared to usb 3.2
with usb4 a 4k movie can be transferred
in under 7 seconds
and the usb4 ecosystem is emerging
rapidly with advanced stocks
ssds and displays leading that charge
we're excited to be an early adopter
helping to enable that ecosystem
pcie gen 4 enables the latest generation
of mobile gpus nvme drives to their full
potential
with twice the speed of pcie gen 3.
most notably the radeon 6000 series
lineup of gpus supports this high-speed
interface from top to bottom ensuring
that phenomenal gpus won't get starved
for data
we've enabled the latest ddr5 or lpddr5
on all ryzen 6000 platforms to ensure
the rdna 2 engine
is properly fed
delivering the optimal graphics
experience
and this is truly a connected platform
our deep partnership with a number of
wireless providers ensures fast
responsive wi-fi 6 and wi-fi 6e
solutions are available on ryzen 6000
laptops
and finally
ryzen 6000 rocks an all-new display
engine delivering the richest visuals of
any notebook platform
hdmi 2.1 and displayport 2 are available
as well as the latest video streaming
standards
such as av1
the ryzen 6000 capabilities at a
platform level are simply incredible
however the system experience
is truly what matters
we've partnered with pcoems and the team
at microsoft to ensure the most premium
components are enabled and optimized in
ryzen-based laptops
from high-end storage to displays to
wireless
we partner to ensure the ryzen 6000
experience is exceptional
to introduce you to this incredible
lineup of partner notebooks let me hand
it back to lisa
thank you jason
now let's look at how our oem partners
are bringing ryzen 6000 to market
i'm excited to start by showing you the
brand new and exclusive lenovo thinkpad
z
the thinkpad z brings the best of
everything we offer with ryzen 6000 to
an all-new thinkpad
amd and lenovo co-designed the thinkpad
z to enable the ultimate collaboration
laptops for business users with the most
advanced security and new features
including premium oled displays a full
hd camera dolby atmos audio and a 3d
haptic touchpad
look for these ultra premium business
notebooks starting this spring in
addition to the thinkpad z we have a
record number of premium commercial
consumer and gaming notebook designs
powered by ryzen 6000 on the way this
year
in fact more than 200 premium designs
are coming from acer asus dell hp lenovo
and razer
we can't wait for these systems to
launch they're truly some of the best
notebooks ever
and to power all those different
notebooks we have 20 different ryzen
6000 mobile processors optimized for
ultra thin commercial and gaming designs
and you should see the first verizon
6000 notebooks starting in february
okay now let's shift our focus to high
performance gpus for that i'd like to
introduce amd fellow and corporate vice
president laura smith
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you lisa
2021 was a great year for radeon
our goal is gaming leadership across the
ecosystem and the journey continues to
be exciting we architected our dna2
graphics for performance scaling
performance per watt leadership and for
broad technology adoption
rdna 2 is the backbone of the rx 6000
series graphics lineup
we first introduced the incredible 4k
performance of the rx 6900 xt
through to the rx 6600 series enabling
high performance 1080p gaming and
features for pc gamers
gaming is an immersive experience
and a great gaming graphics card needs a
great display and software to deliver
the complete experience
we continue to work with display
partners and the amd freesync ecosystem
has grown beyond 2 000 displays
in addition we're certifying even more
premium displays featuring 8k
resolutions and displays with refresh
rates up to 480 hertz
and we're actively working with partners
like samsung display to certify amd
freesync premium pro on qdola displays
for the benefit of nearly all game
developers
graphics hardware and gamers
we launched our open source upscaling
technology
fidelity fx super resolution which gives
an unprecedented performance
improvements to compatible games
at the end of 2021 we had over 45 games
supporting fsr and another 22 are
expected in the first half of this year
fsr is one of the most rapidly adopted
technologies in the industry
2021 was also the year radeon returned
to gaming laptops
leveraging the highly efficient and high
performance rdna 2 architecture we saw
product releases from top oems featuring
the radeon rx 6000m series graphics
now let's jump into 2022 and the new
technologies and products we have to
share with you over the last few years
there has been incredible growth in
gaming laptops
and ultra thin gaming laptops are now
the fastest growing segment at a rate
that is three times faster than
traditional gaming laptops today we are
introducing the amd radeon rx rx6000s
this series is specifically built for
thin and light gaming laptops
these gpus are optimized for power
efficiency and enhanced with new
performance per watt technologies
pushing high performance in the most
compact devices
twenty percent thinner weighing less
than four and a half pounds
as i mentioned last year we introduced
the radeon rx 6000 series lineup for
traditional gaming laptops
this year we're growing the offerings we
are introducing faster performance
graphics solutions with faster memory
and higher game clocks and we are also
expanding the reach of the models in
this series with a new discrete gpu
this new gpu is built on six nanometer
technology designed for low power gaming
today we are announcing a whole lot of
new amd radeon mobile gpus to bring the
best experience to every gaming laptop
for the slim line we have three models
averaging over 80 to 100 frames per
second in the latest aaa and esport
gaming titles for the m series we're
introducing the new rx 6850m
xt
our fastest gpu for extreme gaming
laptops
and new
6650 models delivering up to 20 percent
more performance over the original 6600
m and
a brand new gpu for gamers available in
two models
the amd radeon rx 6300m and the 6500m
for our desktop gamers today we are
introducing a new 6 nanometer gpu that
brings rdna 2 graphics to even more
gamers
the amd radeon rx 6500 xt
this graphics card has the fastest
sustained gpu clock rates ever at over
2.6 gigahertz includes 16 hardware ray
accelerators
16 megabytes of infinity cash
and supports the full suite of
adrenaline software features
let's take a look at the performance of
the rx 6500 xt
almost half of desktop gamers are
playing on a gtx 1650
rx 570 class or lower gpu
games play best with the newest
technology and the rx 6500 xt graphics
card is a substantial upgrade showing an
uplift of up to 59
faster frame rates than your previous
graphics card in aaa and esports gaming
and the radeon rx 6500 xt is optimized
with our full suite of gaming
technologies to supercharge the gaming
experience
pushing frame rates at high settings
well above 60 frames per second with
fidelity fx super resolution
in these three titles gamers can get up
to 46 percent higher frame rates
let's talk about pricing and
availability
the radeon rx 6500 xt partner designs
will be available january 19th starting
at 199
as exciting as 2021 was for amd radeon
our engineers are delivering an even
broader graphics portfolio for 2022.
from eight models introduced last year
we are delivering on our promise to
offer a full portfolio of graphic
solutions with a completely new slim
series lineup for thin and light gaming
even faster premium mobile graphics
solutions
and new discrete graphics accessible for
even more gamers
today all together we are increasing the
number of radeon rx 6000 models to over
18
with the over 300 solutions from system
integrators graphics card partners and
oem designs 2022 is going to be a great
year for all gamers and
do-it-yourselfers i'm excited to
introduce frank azur to tell you more
about radeon software and new amd gaming
solutions
[Music]
thank you laura
at amd we're committed to delivering a
solid stable feature-rich and
high-performing software experience in
2021 we introduced 22 new and improved
features via our amd adrenaline software
including new features like one click
auto overclocking and we made several
updates to popular features like radeon
chill anti-lag and amd link just to name
a few
we've also introduced performance
optimizations resulting in up to 15
faster frame rates from your radeon
graphics cards while also delivering
tuned drivers for over 40 new game
releases on the day they launched
soon we'll be rolling out our next major
adrenaline software release and i'm
excited to share with you today some of
the new features you'll see in it as you
know by now fidelity effects super
resolution has been a huge success with
support from major studios and new
titles are being added weekly
but we challenged ourselves to figure
out a way to give you the benefits of
fsr for all your games
well we've done just that
i'm excited to announce that we've taken
our fsr technology and we've integrated
it into the next version of the
adrenaline software suite
this new feature
is called radeon super resolution and it
allows you to get the performance
benefits of fsr across nearly every game
you own radeon super resolution can be
enabled in two easy steps simply turn it
on in your adrenaline software lower the
resolution in your game settings and rsr
will take care of the rest nearly
doubling your frame rates
rsr is just one of the awesome new
features we have planned for you in this
next release here's a sneak peek of what
more you can expect from the upcoming
adrenaline software release
radeon graphics users will be able to
download the new amd adrenaline software
starting in q1 2022
next let's talk about amd advantage
which we introduced you to last year
with amd advantage we're working to
raise the bar of what defines a great
gaming laptop experience
we've partnered with oems to design
best-in-class gaming laptops by
providing them with a design framework
that ensures the premium performance
delivered by our ryzen cpus and our
radeon gpus is felt through all aspects
of the laptop's experience
there are three key things to know about
amd advantage laptops first we've
amplified their gaming performance by
optimizing amd's cpus and amd's gpus
with our smart technologies
second they come equipped with high
refresh rate and premium quality
freesync displays
and third we focus on each model's
cooling acoustics sleep and resume times
battery life performance and hundreds of
other design decisions making them truly
built to game
when you buy an amd advantage laptop you
can be certain it's been designed from
the ground up to deliver a great gaming
and computing experience
our first amd advantage partners
launched seven different designs with us
featuring all amd hardware and our amd
smart technologies smart shift and smart
access memory
as press and analysts have noticed the
amd advantage design framework takes the
guesswork out of buying a premium gaming
pc and gamers themselves have given us
their overwhelmingly positive reviews
and ratings on these systems
as we continue to challenge ourselves to
raise the bar i'm excited to introduce
you to our 2022 amd advantage design
framework
this year amd advantage devices will
include the new processors and graphics
and software you've been introduced to
here today along with several new amd
smart technologies they'll also include
new freesync premium displays ranging
from 144 hertz to 360 hertz at full hd
resolution and new designs leveraging
quad hd and even 4k screen starting at
120 hertz
and of course all these laptops are
built to game with a minimum of pci 4
nvme drives at least 16 gigabytes of
dual channel ddr5 memory and now a
portfolio of thin and light designs to
complement our new amd ryzen 6000 series
cpus and radeon gpus we've developed a
new set of amd smart technologies to
amplify your performance even further in
these systems
first we're making enhancements to our
smart shift technology
new optimizations for 2022 improve how
your laptop shifts power between the cpu
and the gpu
smart shift max will deliver increased
performance and works better across a
broader set of games and workloads than
original smartship technology did
for example in the game tom clancy's the
division 2 where the original smartship
exhibited no benefits smartshift max is
able to boost performance by an
additional 10 percent when enabled
and in many games that already benefited
from smart shift like strange brigade
smartshift max is able to double the
uplift as compared to the original
next let me introduce you to a new
feature we call smartshift eco
when you unplug your laptop this new
configurable option automatically runs
games on your ryzen cpu's integrated
radeon graphics allowing you to game
longer than ever when on battery
while plugged in games will run on the
full performance of the laptop's radeon
rx discrete gpu delivering maximum frame
rates
this new automation can mean the
difference between gaming for minutes
versus hours when on battery smart shift
eco will be available in amd advantage
laptops later this year
most gaming and creator laptops today
use a hybrid graphics implementation to
offer improved battery life however
there's a performance compromise that
comes with these efficiency benefits as
a discrete gpu must be configured to
display its graphics through the cpu
introducing latency and therefore
lowering frame rates
to solve this we developed amd smart
access graphics
smart access graphics intelligently
switches the display between your ryzen
and radeon processors to optimize
battery life or to enable maximum
graphics performance for an additional
15 percent higher frame rates over
traditional hybrid solutions now let's
take a look at some of the next
generation amd advantage laptops
featuring these new technologies we're
excited to reveal the newest partner to
join the amd advantage lineup
our collaboration with alienware has led
the development of the most powerful
17-inch amd advantage laptop ever built
the alienware m17 r5 features a ryzen
6980 hx cpu a radeon rx 6850m
xt gpu and our latest smart technologies
it's also the first laptop to include
amd smart access graphics
the system comes paired with up to a
gorgeous 120 hertz 4k ultra high
definition freesync premium display with
dolby vision certification
and alienware's cryotech cooling
featuring a vapor chamber design and
element 31 thermal interface material it
also comes with an ultra low profile
cherry mx mechanical keyboard
the alienware m17 r5 amd advantage
edition raises the bar for enthusiast
gaming laptops
two years ago i was on the ces stage
proudly introducing the first asus rog
zephyrus g14 gaming laptop and it's been
a huge hit in the industry redefining
what is possible in a highly mobile and
performant gaming laptop
today i'm excited to announce that the
next generation of the zephyrus g14 will
feature ryzen 9 6000 series processors
and now include radeon thin and light
mobile graphics offering gpus up to a
radeon rx 6800s
along with amd smart shift and smart
access technologies
this laptop will feature a 14 inch high
refresh rate three sync premium
certified display as bright as 500 nits
with rog intelligent cooling and an
enhanced anime matrix display option
along with an ir camera this thin and
night laptop weighs less than three and
a half pounds
the industry's first 14 inch amd
advantage gaming laptop will be
available in select regions in q1
amd advantage laptops make choosing a
great gaming laptop easy
and as a result we've received requests
from partners around the world to offer
their very own branded models
this year multiple system builder
partners such as origin esi tech joy and
many others will release a wide array
built around the amd advantage design
framework
paired with our new ryzen 6000 series
cpus and up to radeon rx 6650 mxt
graphics and supporting the latest amd
smart technologies these systems will
feature up to a 16 inch quad hd freesync
premium display with refresh rates as
high as 165 hertz and they'll be as thin
as 19.9 millimeters
expect to see these laptops launching in
the first half of 2022.
with amd advantage we're bringing the
best gaming laptops to market to keep up
with you while you work create and play
and the response from gamers has been
incredible i'm excited to announce that
in 2022 we'll be launching more than 20
amd advantage laptops with our partners
thank you so much for your time today
let me hand it back over to lisa happy
new year and i hope you have a great
2022.
thanks frank and laura i can't wait for
gamers to get their hands on those new
gpus and advantage laptops
now let's close with the desktop pc
our multi-generational zencore roadmap
has enabled amd to deliver leadership
desktop processors since we first
brought zen to market as the ryzen cpu
in 2017.
today tens of millions of enthusiasts
gamers and creators around the world use
ryzen processors
but we know they always want more more
performance and the latest technology so
let's talk about what's next
at computex last year we showed you a
demo of a ryzen prototype with 3db cache
we're leading the industry in 3d triplet
technology
our approach provides over 200 times the
interconnect density of 2d triplets and
more than 15 times the density compared
to existing 3d stacking solutions this
enables a much more efficient and denser
integration using less than one-third
the energy per signal of competitive
approaches
today i'm excited to announce that we
are bringing 3d triplet technology to
market in our ryzen cpus
the ryzen 7 5800 x3d is our first
verizon processor with 3dv cache
technology
it features eight cores 16 threads up to
four and a half gigahertz boost and a
large 64 megabytes of 3d cache to go
with the 32 megabytes of 2d cache
the 5800x3d drops right into existing
am4 motherboards and delivers a
significant boost in gaming performance
looking at the performance in 1080p
gaming we see a significant increase in
performance in many games with the 96
megabytes of l3 cache
across the entire suite it delivers an
average of 15 percent more frames per
second than our previous fastest gaming
processor the ryzen 9 5900x
and when compared to the competition's
best gaming processor we're proud to say
the combination of the zen 3 core and
amd 3dv cache once again makes ryzen the
fastest gaming cpu in the world
customers often say they just want a
game and want the fastest processor for
the job and the 5800 x3d delivers
and i'm happy to say that ryzen 7
5800x3d
will be available starting this spring
now i want to give you one more update
today on our desktop roadmap
since 2017 we've introduced 123
processors across 12 different product
families in four different technologies
to the am4 platform
that is just a remarkable amount of
innovation
but as always we continue to push the
envelope and i'd like to give you a
preview of our next-gen cpu and platform
zen4 is the next big step
built on five nanometer process
technology
zen4 will extend our performance and
performance per watt leadership in
desktop pcs
for the very first time let me show you
our next generation ryzen processor
this is the all-new 5 nanometer amd
ryzen 7000 desktop processor
it's currently running in our labs and
the performance looks incredible
and just as we did with ryzen 6000
mobile our next gen ryzen desktop
processors will be paired with
next-generation memory and connectivity
technologies to deliver the ultimate
experience
in addition to the new ryzen 7000 cpus
we're introducing an all-new am5
platform
am5 features an lga socket and includes
a support for pci express gen 5 ddr5
memory and much much more
now let's see ryzen 7000 and zenfore in
action for the first time
what you're seeing is 1080p gameplay
footage of halo infinite running on a
pre-production five nanometer ryzen
processor
to give you an idea of why we're so
excited about zenfore you can see
beautiful gameplay at very high frame
rates
and i can tell you that all of those zen
4 cores are running at 5 gigahertz
during this demo
this is the next generation of gaming
and pc experiences from amd
and i'm happy to say that we're on track
to bring ryzen 7000 and am5 to the
market in the second half of this year
how to wrap up it's been fantastic
sharing so much innovation with you
today we're bringing leadership products
to every segment of the pc market
we'll start with radeon 6500 xt
available january 19th
the first notebooks powered by our ryzen
6000 cpus and radeon 6000 gpus will
arrive in february
and ryzen 7 5800 x3d will launch in the
spring
and we are super excited to launch our
next generation ryzen 7000 desktop cpus
in the second half of 2022
i want to thank all of you who have
joined us today on the product premiere
live stream we look forward to a great
2022 and seeing you again soon
[Music]
you